I feel like I'm doing what I'm born to do
as a runner and I'm grateful for that.
I wanna be the best that I can be.
Any athlete, you know, that's trying to learn
how to do something new, like if you do it,
you know, over and over and over again,
eventually you're gonna get it right.
(mellow %music)
I'm doing this for the world.
I'm doing this to, you know, elevate the sport,
to raise the bar and what women think is possible.
I've been known to host an ultra runner
or two here on the show.
And for those of you who enjoy those types of conversations,
you people are in for a treat because Camille Herron,
here in the studio today, is having a moment.
She's breaking world records like a bad habit.
Rewriting history when it comes to human capability.
And, also, re-imagining how we think
about athletic ability as we age.
Among her numerous accolades, Camille has
21 marathon victories to her name.
In 2017, she won the Comrades Marathon.
She's also the first athlete to win world championship
titles in the 50K, 100K, and the 24 hours.
And she has clocked the most miles in 24 hours,
167.8 to be specific, of any woman in history.
Earlier this year, just after turning 40,
Camille beat all the men at the Jackpot 100
and bested her own 100 mile road world record
by clocking 12 hours and 41 minutes.
To better understand just how amazing that is,
she averaged 7.37 per mile for 100 consecutive miles.
In addition, Camille is the youngest woman
to reach 100,000 lifetime running miles.
And she holds my favorite world record,
fastest marathon in a superhero costume
running 2.48 dressed head to toe as spider woman.
She's also, in a way that's sort of similar
to Courtney Dauwalter, just a really
happy and joyous person.
What that's all about is something we'll definitely
get into today, as well as her backstory, of course.
Her unique quality of her quantity training style.
We also talk about how she thinks about the narrowing
of the gender gap in ultra running,
the importance of strength training,
how blood work has impacted her focus on nutrition,
the differences between trail running and road running.
We also discuss her near term goals and future ambitions,
how she manages being married to her coach,
Conor Holt, and how running can be self transcendent.
Needless to say, Camille is just an absolute
force of nature, but she's also just a really fun hang
and quite inspiring, especially for those
of us pondering our athletic capabilities as we age up.
So, please click that subscribe button and here we go.
This is me and Camille Herron.
Well, welcome to Los Angeles.
Thank you.
We have some nice weather for you.
It got pretty warm.
Yeah.
Yeah, it started to warm up.
It's good for you, right?
Yeah, true.
Like, you need a little bit of heat acclimation.
Yeah.
As you're thinking about Badwater sometime in your future.
Yeah, yeah.
I would imagine, right?
Well, I'm training for Western States right now.
I know, that's the big goal at the moment, right?
Yeah.
So, how's it all going?
Oh, great, oh great, I'm super fit.
Yeah, I'm like already, you know, under seven weeks
out right now and I've been road training
and my speed is amazing right now.
I mean, I just won a 40 miler last weekend.
And, I mean, that was a short speed work for me.
Right.
I'm training more for a hundred miles and beyond.
So running, you know, 40 miles was like
a piece of cake it seemed like.
But, I mean, it's still hilly,
so it's kind of priming me for Western States right now.
But, yeah, doing the trail run with Shannon
got me more on trails and I just feel fast.
Good.
Super fast.
Well, you are fast.
I feel fast, yeah.
And that 40 miler last week was a Laz race right?
Yeah.
And you took Harvey down to the mat.
I did, I did, it was super fun.
I mean, like, we love each other and I mean,
it's just, you know, competitive spirit out there.
And, yeah, I mean, when Conor told me that
he was two minutes behind, and then 50 seconds behind,
and I only had a couple miles to go,
I said, it's time to go beast mode.
(both laughing)
Well, you're on, like, quite a tear.
I mean, you've had like an unbelievable
last sort of 18 months.
Yeah.
Of just ticking off world records and winning races.
So, the mojo that you have right now going
into Western States has gotta be pretty empowering.
Oh yeah, absolutely.
You know, of all the races I've got to win,
you know, I've won Comrades and the bucket list,
triple crown of ultras is to win
Comrades, Western States and UTMB.
So, I'm really focused on Western States now.
And, you know, once I can tick that off,
then I can focus on UTMB and try to become the first
athlete to win the triple crown of ultras.
So, but yeah, I won Comrades back in 2017
and, yeah, I've just been focused more
on world records here the past couple years,
and now I'm kind of starting to focus more
on trail running and, yeah, it's just really fun.
Well, you're collecting world
records like it's a bad habit.
(Camille laughing)
I can't even keep track of how many world records you have.
And every time you do a race, multiple records fall
because these races are so long.
And now that you're a master's athlete
you're collecting those along the way as well.
So, it's hard to even know where to start here,
but I think maybe let's begin with the most recent,
like the Jackpot 100 Mile world record,
'cause that's the thing that got a lot
of attention for you all of a sudden
and sort of took you out of the insular
subculture of ultra running and kind of put
you in mainstream awareness because you got
a lot of media attention for that.
So, walk me through how you broke this world record
for running a hundred miles.
Yeah, so fortunately, I ran Jackpot last year
and that was the race that made me realize
I had some issues with my health.
And so, I ended up doing a lot of blood work
right after that race and found out that
I had high iron and low magnesium.
So, I was imbalanced in terms of my minerals.
And so, going into Western States last year,
I had these health issues and I just didn't have time
to really troubleshoot and get my health
in balance for Western States.
So, after Western States in July,
I started working with a dietician
and she was the one that started altering my diet.
I started doing what's called the root cause protocol
to try and get my iron down and get my magnesium up.
And it's kind of this quirky diet that I have to consume.
And so, she was the one that got me,
you know, consuming, changing my diet a bit,
and that was what re-lit the inferno
that I've been missing the past couple years.
So, I was really determined.
I've been on quite a tear.
I won the Javelina Jundred, I went to Desert Solstice.
Yeah, I've just been breaking records.
Right, Desert Solstice was the 24 hour race that you won.
Yeah, so I ended up, I was actually pacing for 24 hours
and I ended up deciding to stop at a hundred miles
because I was having a bit of a knee issue at that race.
But I ended up breaking my world record
for a hundred miles on the track.
So, I still got records at that race.
and then I was able to recover from that race
and go into Jackpot 100, just, you know, really ready
to redeem myself and knew it had a really good
competitive field for both the men and the women.
And so, yeah, training for Jackpot
and the race is in February,
and so it's kind of an early season race
so I wasn't training super hard in January.
I was just training, you know,
pretty modestly going into it.
And then, on top of it, we decided to move
back to Oklahoma which is my home state.
And so, yeah, we did that like, I don't know,
it was like two weeks before Jackpot.
I felt like just getting back to being
around my friends and my family kind of gave
me a bit of a boost going into the Jackpot 100.
And, yeah, I mean, I just went in like, you know,
pretty open minded with, you know,
not knowing if I could go for my world records,
but obviously ready to redeem myself and have
a really good performance after last year's race.
Right, so the Jackpot, for people who don't know,
is in Las Vegas and it's sort of a little bit over,
it's like a 1.2 mile loop or something like that.
You do like 85 loops and what's interesting
is that it's a public park, right?
It's open, like people are walking their dogs
and pushing their kids in strollers
and you kind of have to dodge those people
as you're running around, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Do they even know what's going on?
(Camille laughing)
It's pretty wild.
I mean, when I look at my GPS after the race,
I think I had like a 100.1 miles.
So, you know, who knows how much of that is weaving.
Sidestepping, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm pretty used to that 'cause, like,
when I go to the 24 hour world championship,
I'm weaving around people for 24 hours.
So, obviously, there's a little bit of, you know,
the added challenge of trying not to trip and fall
and a little bit of extra added mileage that you have to do.
But, yeah, I actually going into Jackpot 100,
I mean, the men took off, you know, I let the men go
and I said, I'm gonna run my own race
and just see what happens.
You know, I really trusted myself that I was gonna
be strong later in the race because women
tend to be really strong later in the races.
And so, I just had that trust in myself that I was
going to chase down the men and, sure enough,
it started to happen, you know, after 50 miles.
I mean, I caught a couple of the men.
And then, before I know it, I'm chasing down
the top man, Arlen Glick, after 80 miles.
And so, in my mind, that's like, you know,
taking the bull by the horns.
Like, I grew up in Oklahoma and I always have
this mental image of this bull behind our house
when I grew up and imagine myself, you know,
take the bull by the horns and staring him in the eyes
and just, you know, just ride the bull, you know?
(both laughing)
So, for perspective, you win that race
in 12 hours and 41 minutes, so that's a 7.37 pace, right?
Yeah.
And I think some of your last miles
were around the seven minute mark or even below that.
Like, you were just killing it all the way to the end.
Yeah, yeah, it was super fun.
I think of myself, I grew up as a basketball player
and I think of Michael Jordan, you know,
nailing the free throws, you know, to win the championship.
And, in my mind, that's what it's about.
It's about that feeling of, you know,
being on the free throw line,
trying to nail the free throws.
And so, you know, I channel a lot of thoughts.
Everybody wants to know what's going in my head.
And, I mean, I grew up as a basketball player
learning how to shoot free throws 'cause of my dad.
And so, when I'm in that position to, you know,
take the bull by the horn, shoot the free throws,
I mean, I just really step up my game
and I think that that's what I'm really good at.
You know, bringing out the best of me, you know,
at those clutch moments, when, you know,
I have that opportunity to break a world record
or to win a world championship.
Like, that's what I do best.
Yeah, there's so much in everything you just said
about the nutrition stuff and the blood work,
also the confidence in your race strategy
and how you think about pace.
And I want to get into all of that,
but let's talk about you growing up in Oklahoma.
Your father and your grandfather were both
basketball players at University of Oklahoma.
And there's this sort of legendary story out there
about when you're seven years old
and you're shooting free throws for, like,
hours and hours and hours without water.
Like, this is deeply woven into, like, your DNA.
Like, this idea of persistence and hard work
and determination and athletic prowess.
Yeah, absolutely.
I got it from my dad and my grandpa.
And, you know, there's four kids in my family
and, of all the kids, I was the one that was athletic
and really aspired to be like my grandpa and my dad.
And our mom is also a great athlete as well.
She was a really good swimmer and golfer.
And I was just telling my friend, Shannon,
last night, I was like, the first sport
I learned how to play was actually golf.
We lived out in the country
and I'm the type of person that's pretty OCD.
(Camille laughing)
I mean, I grew up, you know, obviously playing basketball,
dribbling and shooting the ball in the driveway
but golf was actually the sport
that I first learned from my parents.
And I used to hit golf balls, like, just relentlessly.
Like, out into the field.
And then, I would go out there with a bucket
and, you know, grab all these balls.
But, I mean, I wanted to be like my dad and my grandpa,
'cause I'm built like them, I'm tall and lean.
And, yeah, I've just got the athletic genes.
And I mean, my dad, my dad was always like, oh, you know,
we played basketball for six hours without water.
And, you know, you don't wanna tell your...
I could do that.
(Camille laughing)
Exactly, yeah.
In my mind, like, I had it in my mind that I had
to push myself like they did without water.
And I mean, I would do that.
It's not like they forced me to do it.
I just thought that's what I had to do.
And so, I'd be practicing in the driveway
until I'm blacking out and then I would
run inside and my mom would have a big bowl
of sweet tea and make some iced sweet tea
and, like, have a sandwich and soup and pickles
and I would get energized and I would
go back out and I'd keep practicing.
And so, you know, it was like,
I was training for ultras without even realizing it.
Right, right, right.
And it sounds like it was all very self-motivated.
I mean, your father and your grandfather were examples,
but what I didn't hear is you say they were pushing you.
Like, this was coming from within you.
Yeah, absolutely.
I was just relentless.
I just had drive, like, I was competitive, I was driven.
I used to play basketball with the boys in our neighborhood.
And, even at school, I played with the boys.
And, in fact, one of my childhood friends,
he brought up, he remembered me running
in elementary school and I totally forgot about that.
But, I mean, some of my childhood friends remember me,
you know, playing sports with the boys
and I just didn't even think anything of,
you know, them being better than me.
I just grew up with this mindset of I'm gonna beat the boys,
I'm gonna, you know, outrun them,
I'm gonna outplay them on the court,
and, yeah, that was my mindset.
Right, and that's exactly what you're doing today.
(Camille laughing)
Killing all the dudes.
Where do you make the transition from basketball to running?
What was that about?
Yeah, so, I was a pretty good runner in elementary school.
In fact, I totally forget about that,
but my friends bring it up.
We used to run the Presidential Physical Fitness
mile in elementary school.
And I was the best girl at my school.
And they used to actually run
the boys and the girls separate.
And then, I'd be having to compare my time to the boys
'cause none of the girls could keep up.
And so, I always wish I could race the boys
'cause I think I could've, you know, run faster.
But, yeah, then in the seventh grade,
we had to go out for, I was a basketball player
and everybody had to go out for track
for our off season conditioning.
And, from the first day, I mean I could just
run and run and run, just relentless.
Like, I didn't get tired.
And I remember, like, all the other girls.
Shocking, it's shocking.
I mean like your energy is like off the chain.
(Camille laughing)
Yeah, I had so much energy and, I mean,
it makes sense 'cause I was a point guard
on the court and my strategy as a point guard
was always to try and like run all over the place
and wear out whoever was guarding me
and I knew I could outlast them.
And so, when I went out for track, it was obvious,
like, from the first run, I remember running loops
around the school and the other girls would start walking
and I'm just full of energy, I just kept going.
So, yeah, that's kind of what sealed the,
like, planted the seed in my mind, like,
oh, this is really easy for me.
And then, I went out for cross country in the eighth grade
and I remember my first cross country race.
All the other little girls looked like me
and I've always been a string bean and, yeah,
going out for cross country was like this epiphany.
Like, wow, I think this is what I'm supposed to do.
Right, this is my tribe.
Yeah.
All these kids look like me like
and they're into the same stuff and all of that.
Yeah.
And that was that from then on out.
Oh, I was hooked, I was absolutely hooked.
I mean, cross country, because we grew
up out in the country running
around the wheat fields by our house,
and cross country was that same feeling.
Like, I felt like cross country is what really
got me hooked on running and I felt like that's
what my calling is to, you know, to be a runner.
And so, I actually didn't get my height until I was
in high school after I had quit basketball.
And so, it's really funny because, you know,
maybe I could have gone on with a basketball.
Like, I wonder, you know?
Yeah.
In fact, my husband bought me a basketball
a couple years ago and he had never seen me
with a basketball and he was just really shocked.
And I hadn't even practiced or done anything in years.
And my husband just saw this whole
other side of me as an athlete.
And, yeah, I mean, it's kind of funny to wonder,
you know, what if I had gone on with the basketball?
Yeah, like some kind of sliding doors thing,
where had you just moved a little bit over in the other
direction you'd be playing in the WNBA right now.
Yeah.
And breaking records for, you know,
I don't know, being one of the older people
doing it and still killing everyone.
Yeah, yeah, I mean, I think I could have been,
I could have probably, you know, been a good rower.
I probably could have been good endurance
for any other sport, you know, that's comparable.
I mean, I learned how to row like 10 years ago
and I just easily picked it up.
And I almost thought, like, do I switch sports?
You could do an Ironman.
Your mom was a swimmer, right?
Yeah.
There's that, too.
I wasn't really a swimmer.
I was more of a land sport athlete.
But, yeah, funny enough, I did not become a swimmer
because I fell into a pool when I was three
and I almost drowned and my mom had to dive in
and get me and I was pretty traumatized from the water
and that's pretty much why I did not become a swimmer.
That was it.
Oh, that's so sad.
We could work through that trauma.
(Camille laughing)
I know.
We can unpack that here and get you back in the pool.
So, you've just surpassed your 100,000th mile of running.
Yeah.
I don't know how you've tracked all of this
going all the way back to then.
I guess it's a bit of an honor system
in this world of, like, people who have
run more than 100,000 miles, but it began back then.
And it sounds like you had success from the outset.
I mean, what was it like in high school when you were
running cross country and developing your skill?
Yeah, so, when I first started tracking my mileage
and was like kind of loosely back in junior high
and high school and just kept a calendar.
And my dad is, you know, he's like a statistician
and historian and he's kind of the one
that planted the seed to be able to track my mileage,
to see what my training load is, you know,
and try to figure out, you know,
not to increase my mileage too much and that sort of thing.
So, I just kind of loosely tracked it back then.
But I actually started tracking in more detail
back in 2002 when I was in college.
I was in a research study at Stanford
and I had to start tracking my mileage
back then, like, in more detail.
And so, that's when I started keeping
my first proper training log.
And I have all my mileage tracked since 2002.
Wow.
And, yeah, and because I'm a bit of a stats geek,
which, you know, I credit to my dad,
and I learned how to do spreadsheets
keeping stats, you know, with spreadsheets.
And, like, I have all this, like, detailed information
on like injuries and just, yeah, like paces, everything.
Right, numbers geek.
Yeah.
And I think, with that, I think you're
the youngest to have surpassed 100,000 miles?
Yeah.
Right, so there's another record.
(Camille laughing)
There's no end to how many records you're breaking,
but I love the attention to detail
and the math and the statistics.
I think, you know, I'm sure you get compared
to Courtney Dauwalter, like all the time, right?
And there's so many, just in spending
a few minutes with you, I can already,
like, identify all these sort of similar personality traits.
Like the joyfulness, the happiness, the enthusiasm.
And there is a sort of happy go lucky attitude.
But I think what just differentiates you from her
is that, like, attention, like the math side of you, right?
Yeah, yeah, I'm a math geek.
I was on the math team when I was in junior high
and academic teams and I credit my dad for being the one
that, I mean, I used to help my dad
with baseball cards and learning baseball stats.
And so, when I got into running, I'm learning running
stats and, you know, times, and track and field.
And, yeah, I'm a total, like, running dork, so.
Right, right, right.
So, you go on to this illustrious career on the road.
I mean, you've won like 21 marathons, is that right?
Yeah.
And you won Comrades, that was in 2017?
I mean, that had to be a career highlight,
winning that crazy race.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
I actually, after I won Comrades, I thought I could retire.
(Camille laughing)
Yeah, I mean, what's left?
With all those thousands of people cheering you on.
I mean, I can't imagine much could live up to that.
No, I, yeah, I literally, the month after that race,
I was like, I think I can retire now.
And I had to reformulate my goals and I realized like,
oh, there's all these world records I can go after.
And, you know, that was kind of at the beginning
of my ultra career and a lot of people
were trying to push me into trail running
and I started getting my feet wet and doing trail running,
but I really had to follow my heart
and my heart was telling me to go after the world records.
So, after I won Comrades in June,
later in the fall is when I started studying,
like, the 12 hour, 100 mile world records.
And, yeah, that was, you know,
what started me like, yeah.
You're like, this is easy.
(Camille laughing)
This is like low hanging fruit for me.
I think it's unique and interesting that you're coming
into ultra running with this illustrious career on the road.
So, you have all this speed, right?
Like a lot of people who get into ultra running
don't have that type of background
or that type of success in other areas of running.
So, you're bringing this new elite level
of, like, being able to just crush it
in terms of pace that's new.
And then, the question becomes, can that be extended, right?
And you're proving, like, actually it can.
And that's the way that you train also.
You're still training like an elite marathoner,
not like how we think about ultra distance trail runners
where it's just go out and run really long
as many times a week as you possibly can.
Yeah, exactly.
I think that that's what differentiates me
is that I had a marathoning career for 10 years
and I just brought my marathon training
approach into ultra running.
And, literally, for my first 100K,
I broke my first record by Anne Trason.
And, I mean, I was pretty naive.
I didn't know how ultra runners train.
I didn't even know who Anne Trason was.
Like, I'd read about her.
I guess everybody read "Born to Run"
and I had read that back when I was a marathoner,
but I didn't really know, like,
anything about the sport, how the athletes train.
I just came into the sport with a marathon
training approach and started breaking records.
And I figured, why change what works?
And so, I've been able to go longer
with marathon training and continue to break the records.
And I haven't really found, you know,
a limitation to the way that I train.
Obviously, if I'm training for trail,
I do more trail running, but I'm still, you know,
that foundation of being a marathon training, you know,
works for, it's worked all the way up to 24 hours so far.
Right, and you're not doing crazy long runs.
Like, your longest runs are between 18 and 22.
And you only do that every couple weeks, right?
Yeah, yeah, in fact, I was just telling my friend,
Shannon, this morning, I was like, the longest training
run I've done the past five years is 22 miles.
Wow.
Yeah, and so, I told her, I was like,
the only time I ever go further than that is if I race.
So, it's almost like the races.
You are racing a lot.
Yeah.
So, that is part of the training.
Yeah, definitely.
I mean, you know, I just ran a 40 miler last weekend,
you know, why do I need to do more long runs,
you know, when I just ran 40 miles?
So, I think, you know, racing is training.
You know, racing develops your fitness as well.
And so, I just really focus on recovering
between my races and making sure I feel really good
and do a lot of quality work, which is really important.
Trying to keep in touch
with my leg speed is super important.
I find if I get away from my leg speed
too much that I get a little bit flat.
And so, you know, coming from a short distance background,
I still kind of have to tap into that.
Yeah, a couple observations with that,
just so people aren't confused.
It's not like you're not training.
I mean, you run twice a day, most days, right?
Yeah.
So, you're still crossing over the a hundred miles
a week mark pretty consistently, right?
Yeah, yeah.
I get in, you know, 100, 130 miles per week,
but I do it in 12 to 13 runs a week.
Right.
So, yeah, I'm just doing mainly short frequent runs.
And then, you know, every couple weeks
I might do a long run or I'll do a race.
But, really, it's just, you know,
I feel like I recover really well with my training approach
and I feel really good and energized
and it makes me feel really fresh
and strong when I go into races that
I'm not beat down from a lot of long runs.
And, yeah. in fact, when I first got into the sport,
I mean, I kind of experimented with doing,
you know, 30 mile plus training runs.
And I found that I just felt tired trying to do that.
So, when I went back down to shorten my long runs
and went back down to only 18 to 22 mile long runs
every couple weeks that's when I started to feel fresher.
Right, fresher, able to bounce back more quickly.
And that way your training sessions
are of a higher quality, in general, right?
Yeah.
Your husband, Conor, is here.
He's your coach, he has been for a long time.
I'm interested in getting, like,
really nitty gritty and detailed about the training.
Like, how much of it is, what is the ratio of,
like, the easy runs to the hard tempo speed work?
Like, it appears that you train on the polarities.
Either you're going really chill or you're,
you know, crushing intervals at, you know,
at the other end of that spectrum.
Yeah, actually Strava is really helpful
for knowing kind of the stats on my training.
I think that, last year, it said that 86%
of my training was easy and considered an easy pace.
And what's easy?
So, for me, like, I guess on road, that would
be like an eight to nine minute per mile pace.
On trail, it might be quite a bit slower.
But, yeah, I mean, I'm going about 65 to 70%
of max heart rate effort as my easy pace.
And so, yeah, I mean, I'm doing, you know,
86% is pretty aerobic, easy type of training.
And then my hard days are very hard
and, like, I might be doing, like,
I don't know, anywhere between six to 18 miles
at, like, a pretty hard, hard effort.
And so, we operate pretty much on a two week
training cycle where we have short intervals,
long intervals, a hill session, and a progression run.
So, in between those four main workouts, it's just easy,
you know, aerobic training, running twice a day.
And so, yeah, being a 24 hour runner,
I have to be used to training, you know,
multiple times a day and being comfortable, you know,
early morning or late at night.
And so, yeah, I just get myself comfortable for that.
Right.
So, yeah, you like to do the evening runs don't you?
Yes.
How much of the tempo and hard efforts are,
like, track based or interval based, you know,
in that kind of traditional track and field approach
versus like, oh, I'm just going out on the road
and it's gonna be six miles at this level of intensity?
Yeah, I mean, I guess if I'm doing 14% of my training,
I mean, I do like 90 second repeats
is like kind of my short sprint type workouts.
I mean, that's like, I usually do it on road, too.
I don't do it on track, I hate the track.
(Camille laughing)
Which is really funny.
I absolutely hate the track.
I don't train on the track at all.
So, I do everything on road and I do like 90 second repeats,
maybe like five to six minute long intervals,
sometimes, maybe two miles or three mile intervals,
which might be like half marathon or marathon pace.
And then, my progression runs might be anywhere
between 30 to 60 minutes where I progress
it from about 80% of max heart rate effort up to 90%.
And so, yeah, when I race 50 miles to a 100K,
I equate that to about 80% of max heart rate effort.
And then, when I run a hundred miles,
it's like 75% of max heart rate.
And then, when we do 24 hours,
that's more like a super chill,
like 65 to 70% of max heart rate.
And you wear a heart rate strap, chest strap,
to gauge all of that and monitor it?
Yeah, yeah.
What's your max heart rate?
Yeah, actually, I've kind of gotten,
it hasn't really dropped that much since I've been tested.
I was tested when I was in grad school
on a treadmill and figured it out.
I think, back then, I think it was like maybe 198.
And, yeah, I mean, like 15 years later,
it's still like probably about 192 to 194.
Wow.
So, if you're running a hundred mile ultra
and you're trying to keep it right at 75% of max
for the whole time, that's like,
what, 145 or somewhere around that, right?
Yeah, yeah, about 145 to 150.
But I don't wear my heart rate strap during the race.
I just practice it in training and get a feel
for the effort that I wanna go at.
And then, when I do the race, it's all just effort based.
And then, eventually, like, you know,
80 miles into the race in my mind.
Forget that and then you just go.
Yeah.
(both laughing)
Just ditch it and just run as hard as I can, yeah.
Do you do proper lactate testing also?
I haven't done that, in fact...
For a numbers geek, I'm surprised.
I know, I know.
But, funny enough, like, my research
that I did as an undergrad was blood lactate
testing with strength training.
And so, I got familiar with blood lactate
I've actually never done it on myself,
but when I do my heart rate based progression runs,
I push it up to the point where I start to feel my blood
lactate and know what my heart rate is for that.
And then, I train so that my heart rate is just below that,
so that, you know, I'm training my blood lactate threshold.
Right, so you have this massive
aerobic capacity where you can train
and race at 75 to 80% of max heart rate
without creeping into that anaerobic zone.
But it would be cool, though.
It would be amazing to look at that graph
and to see where it is exactly and then track it over time.
Because I think what's really interesting about you,
now being 40 and being this master's athlete
and somebody who's entered the sport
with a huge amount of speed, obviously,
as we get older, the speed becomes harder to hold onto.
And that's like your secret weapon right now.
So, it's like double down on that.
How can I leverage this speed and, you know,
blow the lid on all these world records?
But, at the same time, what's exciting is that
as that speed will naturally wither with age
just no matter what you do, you have this
whole realm of continuing to be able to develop
your aerobic capacity as an endurance athlete, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Which is sort of like with you doing
the shorter stuff and not doing the longer stuff,
I feel like there's a lot of room to grow there
that will serve you well as you kind of continue along.
Yeah, well, I feel like definitely
I'm physically stronger since I've gotten older.
And I know that because when I start to do,
like, these progression runs, you know,
starting at like my a hundred mile effort,
like 75% working up to 80, 90%,
my pace is faster and it feels easier.
And I, like, the things I'm doing now,
I couldn't do five years ago.
I've just got this strength,
this physical strength that I didn't have.
And so, I feel like maybe what I had,
there's kind of been this shift in, like,
you know, maybe I was faster, you know,
10 years ago, but I didn't have the strength
and now I'm kind of like more strength
and able to hold that speed.
Right.
So, it's really interesting.
I feel like I'm like in my prime right now.
I've, like, got this really good balance
for both speed and strength and it's really more
my strength that is allowing me to do amazing things.
Right, and you have been doing more strength work, right?
Like, I know you got like a squat rack
and you are kind of focused on that
in a way that you didn't used to.
Yeah, yeah, we bought a squat rack a year ago
and, I mean, I'd always worked like my upper body
and I'd always just let the training,
like, take care of my lower body.
But I was in a car accident three years ago
and I injured my back and I've had a lot
of breakdown on the right side of my body
and I've had to drop from races
because my body was breaking down.
And I finally said, you know, I need to work on this.
I need to work on whole body strength.
And so, we bought the squat rack
and working my back has made such a difference.
Like, it's just kind of unraveled all these kinks
that I had developed on the right side of my body.
And I feel that when I race.
Especially, like, later when I'm running a hundred miles,
I feel it later in the race, like, I feel like my form
Stable.
And my posture is a lot better.
In addition to squats, what other
dry land strength stuff do you do?
Gosh, yeah, I mean, we've got a gym
and I have, like, a bench.
And I've really kind of, I mean, I've gone
through different protocols over the years
of just either doing upper body
or some combo of upper body and lower body.
And, really, I've just got it down
to four main exercises that I do.
And so, I do the bench press and pushups
and squats and dead lifts and that's it.
That's it.
Yeah.
That's cool.
But it seems to be working, right?
Absolutely.
And I love this idea of racing at 75% of max heart rate.
Like, it's so simple.
Yeah.
And that just, then, dictates your strategy.
So, you mentioned earlier at Jackpot and these other races,
like, the men dart off the starting line,
and it's easy to fall into, like,
forgetting about your race strategy.
Oh my God, they're getting away, I need to like match pace.
But you're like, nope, this is what I'm doing.
Yep.
This is a long day, right?
Yeah.
And then, you know, come eight hours into it or whatever,
you start to, like, you know, oh, there they are.
They're falling apart and I'm still good.
Just stick to what I'm doing.
Because, in those races, you're not
really racing anyone else.
No.
You're just racing yourself, right?
Yeah.
And to have a clear strategy that works for you
and the confidence to maintain it,
even when there's all this other stuff
happening around you that you can't control,
I think is really powerful.
Totally.
I just think I have a bit of maturity in the sport
that I feel like I'm a veteran now
and that I can be more confident in,
you know, pulling back the reins
earlier in the race and trusting that
I can sustain it better later in the race.
And so, I think it's just taken me time to get that feeling
and to know that I don't have to go out with the men.
That I can pull it back and, you know,
kind of work more with my natural physiology.
And it's been working really, really well.
And even, you know, on the trails.
And, yeah, everybody's like, well,
how do you translate that effort to the trails?
And I feel like I have such a good sense
of what 75% effort feels like that,
even when I get on the trails, I can channel that effort.
And, yeah, and I just have, you know,
that confidence that later in the race
I'm gonna, you know, start to gain on the men.
Yeah, well, you've been killing it on the track
and on the road, and I think you would agree,
like, you've excelled in these road ultras
and in races that are relatively flat.
I mean, Jackpot had 3,000 feet
of elevation gain and you broke the world record.
Like, what would've happened on a totally flat track?
Yeah.
I guess we'll find out 'cause you'll,
no doubt, do that at some point.
But trails is sort of a new
terrain for you to conquer, right?
Yeah.
A lot of elevation gain, a lot of technical running.
Like, how are you reconfiguring your training,
or maybe you're not, to figure out that equation?
Yeah, well, I found that I tend to do
better on the trails if I'm really more
focused on road to get my turnover going.
Even running this morning, I mean,
I got on trails with a lot of, like,
climbing and descent and I was like, whoa.
I mean, I grew up, like just to kind of give the analogy,
I grew up playing the french horn
and we used to buzz into the mouth piece.
And once you'd put the mouth piece on the instrument,
you're just like, woo, like just kind
of like singing on the instrument.
And that's kind of what it feels like
when I really channel a lot of my road training
and my leg speed and then bring it to the trails.
It's just like I'm flying uphill and downhill.
And I think that, really, the key for me
that I found when I have done, like,
kind of more technical trail races is I just have to,
like, practice and get that technical skill.
And I've been really working on that the past year.
We lived in Arizona for a while and I was running
on more like technical rocky stuff.
And I feel like I kind of gained a better sense
of how to control my body on more technical terrain.
And it's actually becoming more fun.
Like, I think, like, maybe five, six years ago
when I got into trail running, it was kind of intimidating.
And, now, I feel like I'm kind of,
like, getting that sense of how to control
the movement of my body on technical terrain.
And so, yeah, I mean, obviously I've been
more focused on road and track stuff,
but I'm really, really excited to get into more
trail running and just see what I can do.
Yeah, I think the strength training
probably is very helpful in that,
like, sort of body stability
'cause now you're kind of all over the place.
Yeah.
I mean, when you're on the road or the track,
it's like a metronome, right?
Yeah.
Like, you just get into your pace and you just do
your thing and you're doing these loops or whatever,
and it becomes this mental game.
But it's very steady state, right?
Whereas, in a trail, even when it's an ultra,
like, you're up, you're down,
you're flat, you're descending.
Like, your heart rate isn't gonna be,
like, completely in the same place every time.
Yeah.
So, it's about training your body to be able
to come back to baseline more quickly or be able
to bounce back and adapt to all of those different inputs.
Yeah, I think it's fun.
Even, I mean, I went and ran Javelina last fall
and getting back on trail and, you know,
just flowing with that terrain and the technicality.
I feel like I'm gaining a better sense of how to,
I guess, like throttle my gears, like a bike.
You know, knowing when to pull back and when to push.
And it's fun for me.
I feel like, like you said, I mean,
I'm used to the road and track stuff being a metronome,
but I get on trail and it's kind of this,
like, you know, throttling your gears
and learning how to move with the terrain.
And it's fun, it's beautiful.
I really like the camaraderie out there.
Like just, you know, going through the aid stations
and seeing people and they're cheering me on,
and like that really amps you up.
Yeah, yeah.
Are you thinking who is your competition at Western States
or do you not even think about that?
You're just thinking about what you need to do for you.
Yeah, I think I'm really somebody
that focuses internally on my own effort.
And, yeah, I mean, I think it's been working really well,
that I've been more channeling my own internal effort
and then, you know, maybe catching people later in the race.
And, I mean, it takes confidence to be able to do that.
You know, to be able to say that, okay,
maybe I need to hold back earlier in the race
to be stronger later in the race.
And, yeah, I mean, I think everybody's kind of known
me as somebody that goes out really hard.
And, obviously, you know, I work
at a different pace than most people.
So, even like me looking like I'm going out hard,
I might be still pulling it back, you know.
In my mind, I'm running controlled and, you know,
waiting for 80 miles or later in the race to,
you know, really just kick it in.
How do you think about the gender gap?
Because in ultra running, maybe more than
almost any other sport, we're seeing the women
excel at a level in terms in comparison,
like in this ratio, to men's performances
that I think is super fascinating.
Like, the endurance capacity of the female body,
particularly as we get older, the proof is in the pudding.
Like, you're matching stride for stride with the guys,
if not beating them outright.
I mean, Harvey Lewis is one of the best ultra runners
in the world and you just beat him in a 40 miler last week.
Like, it's crazy, right?
Yeah.
And I think when you look at world record
comparisons between men and women,
I don't know how it breaks down in terms of that ratio,
but it's much slimmer in ultra running, right?
Like, you're 100 mile world record compared to the men's,
you know, they're not going that much faster than you.
Yeah.
Well, that was the thing that was really interesting.
It seemed like the longer I went that the closer the gap
got between me and the men's world records.
And it's funny because now the men's world records
have been raised by Aleksandr Sorokin.
Yeah, that Lithuanian guy, right?
Yeah, yeah.
So, I think I was running, I think I was at like 9.4%
off the men's hundred mile world record,
and then he's taken it to...
He crushed it.
He's taken it to a whole other level.
But that's the way it's supposed to be.
Yeah.
Now you have something more to chase.
Exactly.
I feel like, I mean, I'm inspired by what he's doing
and it actually motivates me thinking, okay,
maybe I need to really step up my game for a hundred miles.
Yeah, what did he do, 11.41 or something like that?
What was his?
Oh, gosh, I think he did like 10.51.
Oh yeah, 10.51, so he is running 6.31 miles.
Yeah, it's amazing.
And, I mean, the record before he started breaking it
was by Zach Bitter, I think he had run like 11.19.
Right.
So, I mean, he's almost improved it by 30 minutes
and it's like, oh my gosh, I need to get on a track,
improve my world records.
And so, yeah, I mean, it's super cool to see.
I mean, I was doing it, you know,
setting world records and then Zach Bitter did it,
and then now Sorokin's doing it.
I mean, we just keep raising the bar.
Right.
It's super cool.
But I think on the right conditions
you could break 12 hours.
Yeah.
Don't you think?
I think I can.
John Olson, he was on the 24 hour team,
so John Olson, I think I surpassed John Olson
for 24 hours and he's run 11.59 for a hundred miles.
So, that kind of puts me in the ballpark of, like,
could I run 11.50 something for a hundred miles?
Yeah.
But it's gonna take like the right conditions
and you know, probably being on a track
and just being really dialed in for that.
Right, right, right.
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated by scores of beautiful
and brilliant people who have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know can teach us
something new and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so, I've dedicated my career to tracking
down the most compelling prophets on the planet.
Going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce the release
of my new book, "Voicing Change", volume two.
More than mere words on paper, "Voicing Change"
is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration and timeless wisdom that transpires
each week on "The Rich Roll Podcast".
The first edition of "Voicing Change" was a beautifully
rendered book worthy of display on any coffee table.
And volume two follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication replete with interview excerpts,
essays, and stunning photography
making for an exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit
the wisdom of your favorite everyday prophets
and physically interact with the life
changing ideas contained within.
"Voicing Change" volume two available now
while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
I want to go back to this nutrition piece
'cause you mentioned getting blood work
and having some indications that
you needed to make some corrections.
I don't want to just blow past that
'cause I think that's really interesting.
So, tell me more about how you were feeling?
You get this blood test, you get these results,
and kind of what happened?
Yeah, well it was pretty shocking.
I mean, you hear of endurance athletes
getting anemia and having low iron,
and I found out I had the opposite problem.
So, I had high iron and I think the thing is,
like a lot of athletes think that
they just have to test their ferritin.
And I ended up having a full iron panel done
with InsideTracker and all these
iron markers were, like, way off the charts.
And I was just shocked because, here I've been
checking my ferritin for many years
and it's always been like kind of in the normal range.
And then, I go and get all these other
iron markers tested and they're like off the charts.
And it totally made sense to me because here,
I was just having trouble, like,
I almost thought I was anemic.
I felt like I was having symptoms that mimicked anemia
because I was really tired in my training
and I'm trying to take more iron thinking that I'm anemic
and then find out that I ended up having high iron.
And so, it was just really shocking.
And I found that it's actually hard to get your iron down.
Right, you can supplement to boost it,
but how do you lower it if it's high?
Yeah.
Without, like, blood letting or donating blood, right?
So, I mean, your body recycles iron.
From what I've learned is your body's recycling iron.
So your body actually holds on to iron pretty well.
And so, I've had to, like, work with a dietician
with kind of these quirky, like,
balancing my copper and my magnesium and like,
because it all kind of interplays together.
But I've been having a lot of blood taken out,
like blood draws for blood tests the past year,
and, you know, if I wasn't an endurance athlete,
I would probably be donating blood, like a pint of blood,
to try and get my iron down because that's
really the solution to really get it down.
But being an endurance athlete,
if I had a pint of blood taken out,
who knows how it would impact my recovery.
Yeah, yeah.
So, it's interesting, you're using InsideTracker.
I just started using it and we're working with them
on the podcast and I just got my blood results
back and my ferritin was low, but my iron was high.
Yeah.
I don't know what that means.
And I was like, I need to figure
out what that means exactly.
How can my iron be high and my ferritin
levels be on the lower side?
Yeah, yeah.
I've actually asked my dietician about that.
I'm like, why is, are all my markers high,
and then some people are like low,
but then still like transparent saturation
or whatever could be high?
And she says, it's like iron dysregulation.
I guess, like, the body could be under a lot of stress.
And so, for some reason, like, it just causes,
like, this imbalance of the markers.
So, yeah, I would suggest working with a dietician
because they're kinda the brains to know what to do.
But it is unusual that you have
these high, high ferritin levels.
What causes that?
Was it because you were supplementing thinking you were low?
Or what contributed to your iron levels being so high?
Yeah, so I actually had the genetics test done
for hemochromatosis and I don't have the genetics,
but apparently my body just naturally,
like, really absorbs and holds onto iron.
And so, when we were living in Colorado,
I was supplementing with iron thinking that
that was the sensible thing to do.
And because I learned since then that my body,
like, retains iron really well,
and I started getting really tired living in Colorado.
And that was when I thought, you know, like,
is my body just not doing well?
Like being at high altitude?
Yes, well, the altitude must have had some
impact on it as well because it's telling your body,
like, we need more red blood cells,
the iron is what captures the oxygen.
Yeah, it was really interesting living in Colorado
feeling like something in my body's just off.
And I thought I needed more iron
and I'm trying to supplement with more iron,
not knowing that my body holds onto iron really well.
And so, I was just making the problem
worse without knowing it.
And so, we ended up deciding to move
back down to lower altitude thinking,
well, the high altitude isn't working for me.
But the funny thing is, like, if I had been living
at high altitude and not supplementing with iron,
I probably would've been okay because it probably
would've helped to better regulate my iron
and keep my blood values down
and I probably would've felt fine.
But the fact that I was supplementing with iron when
my body didn't need it, it just went like, just crazy.
Right.
And how long has it taken to get it back to normal?
Yeah, so, I mean, I've been on this special diet
for a year and some of my iron markers are still
a little bit high, but they've gotten down,
but I'm just going by how I feel.
I've felt so much better since I've been working
with this special diet and having,
like, these minimal blood draws done.
And what is the diet, specifically?
What does it look like?
I don't know how to describe what I'm doing.
It's called the root cause protocol.
And so, It was supposed to rebalance, like,
it's supposed to, like, taking in more copper
and trying to get my copper up,
and I've been taking a lot of magnesium
because my magnesium was low as well.
And so, I guess, if you wanna know, like, the chemistry,
you know, you're working with all these cations,
these two plus cations, because iron is a two plus cation.
And so you're trying to rebalance and restrict the iron
absorption by taking in more of the the two plus cations.
Right I don't even, what does that mean, cations?
(Camille laughing)
Yeah, the chemistry, I know, I'm like, yeah.
So, what foods are high in copper?
Like, do you supplement with that or is that just
in the choices of foods that are on your plate?
Yeah, I'm kind of like leaving that up to the dietician,
but, I mean, I'm taking a lot of nuts.
There's a lot of different nuts that I'm taking.
There's like B pollen, I'm taking mineral drops
that have like boron in them
and a bunch of different things.
And yeah, it's kind of quirky, I don't really know.
I'm taking, like, a lot of sodium,
which is also two plus cation.
And so, it's kind of this quirky balance that is supposed
to rebalance my minerals and I'm just working with it.
Yeah, no, I got it.
And this also affects how you fuel during races, right?
You're taking, like, mineral drops in the middle of a race.
Yeah.
So, tell me about how you think
about race nutrition and how that works.
Yeah, so one of the symptoms of, I think,
of the whole iron overload is I started having GI issues.
Even going back to the 24 hour
world championship back in 2019.
And so, I think, like, when you have a lot of iron
in your body, it causes oxidative stress.
And so, it was kind of stressing my gut.
It was stressing like, just like a lot of,
I was having a lot of weird health issues.
And so, since we've been able to rebalance
my minerals and my iron and taking mineral drops
during races, like, I stopped having my gut problems.
And it's been amazing because I'm somebody that has
generally not had gut problems during races.
I'm somebody that has a bit of an iron gut.
So, for me to be getting gut problems
during races was really unusual.
And so, yeah, since we've changed my diet
and I'm putting like mineral drops in my water during races,
like, I feel like a million bucks.
Wow, that's super interesting.
Yeah, it really is.
Because I haven't really heard a story like that before.
Yeah.
But I think that's fascinating.
It would be good to see, like, a full study
on what exactly it is that you're doing.
I'm sure a lot of people would be interested in that.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm actually working with InsideTracker
and they're tracking my blood markers
leading up to Western States.
Oh, cool.
And so, yeah, and I've had a lot of blood work
the whole past year and even looking at things like
Vitamin A, Vitamin D, just all these biomarkers.
And so, it's really interesting.
I mean, I just know that I feel better
and I feel like, you know, regardless of what
the biomarkers say, I know that I feel better
and I'm obviously like, you know, breaking world records.
Yeah, you definitely have a lot of energy.
(both laughing)
Yeah.
So something is going well.
And what is the calorie fueling
and electrolyte process when you're racing?
Like, do you do increment, like every 30 minutes,
you take X, Y, and Z, like, what is that, specifically?
Yeah, so, obviously, working for 24 hours and under,
like, I can get by, pretty much,
mostly on gels and water and sports drink.
And I only deviate from that
when I feel like I need something different.
So, everybody knows the story about me taking like tacos
and burritos when I've done my 24 hour races.
But, yeah, I mean, I can,
even for my a hundred mile world records,
I mean, every 30 minutes I was taking a gel with water
and then just sipping sports drink.
And the only thing that I deviated was,
like, 70 miles into the race, I felt like I wanted
something different and I stopped for 15 seconds
and shotgunned a non-alcoholic beer.
Yeah.
(Camille laughing)
I had read that, that's so funny.
And you, I mean, you're you like your beers,
but you kind of got off the alcoholic beer
because of how that increases iron absorption, right?
Yeah, yeah.
When I started learning, you know,
about my high iron and trying to learn, like,
what do I need to do differently?
And, yeah, me and my husband are,
you know, beer connoisseurs, we love our beer.
I mean, we drink, in fact, we used to home brew beer.
And so, I mean, we just love beer.
But it actually was not that difficult
to get off of, you know, stop drinking
our regular IPA's every night for dinner
'cause we ended up switching to non-alcoholic beer.
And, yeah, I mean, there's some really
great non-alcoholic beers out there.
So, if anybody's wanting to get off of alcohol,
I mean there's some great non-alcoholic options out there.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, cool.
And what does recovery look like?
You mentioned that you're really prioritizing
that these days, so what does that mean?
Yeah, I've definitely seen a change in my sleep,
especially with the magnesium,
I've kind of experimented with my magnesium.
I think I'm taking like 700 milligrams a day
by supplement, which is quite a bit.
Which supplement?
Do you use the calm or which?
What is the one specifically you use, do you know?
Yeah, so there's like two different magnesium
ones I use, they're by Jigsaw Health.
I think it's a Magnesium Malate and MagSoothe.
And then I take the mineral drops as well.
So I'm taking something like 300 milligrams
of the mineral drops and then I'm taking, like,
another 200 of Magnesium Malate, I think that's right.
Yeah, something like that.
But it comes out to like 700 milligrams of magnesium.
And I've seen, as I increased my magnesium drops,
that I've seen, like, a change in my sleep.
And so, that's been huge.
Right.
Like, I feel like I'm recovering
so much better since I've gotten my sleep.
I was averaging, like, seven hours at night
and now I'm like up to eight hours
and then taking a two hour nap during the day.
Wow, that's huge.
Yeah.
Do you take the magnesium at night
or it doesn't matter when you take it during the day?
Yeah, so I usually take the Magnesium Malate
for breakfast and lunch and then
take the MagSoothe at nighttime.
And then, the mineral drops I take it in my water
and my coffee, like, throughout the day.
So, I think I'm just pretty much taking it all day.
And then, also, when I go do races,
I'm taking mineral drops during the races as well.
Right, right, right.
When you did InsideTracker,
was your magnesium levels low or no?
Yeah.
They were.
So, trying to get my magnesium up has been
really challenging 'cause it was really low
on InsideTracker, but it has gone up and I know,
like, just based on how I feel and how I'm sleeping,
like, and I feel a difference in my muscles
when I run and that, you know, whatever,
even if the biomarkers aren't necessarily,
like, up to where they should be,
I just know that the way I feel is so much better.
Right, so nine hours of sleep a night plus two hour nap.
Yeah.
Are you wearing a sleep tracker?
Do you do, like, Oura Ring or the Whoop
or anything like that?
Yeah.
So I have COROS, the COROS watch
and I track, like, my deep sleep.
And, I mean, I'm getting like two
to two and a half hours of deep sleep a night.
That's good.
Yeah, really good sleep.
And I mean, it's incredible.
And it's really interesting to see, like, after races
and my sleep might be off for like a week or so,
but then I go back into, like, this really deep sleep
and I'm just, like, super, like, charged and feeling good.
How long does it take you to bounce back from these races?
Yeah, it's been incredible.
Like, I feel like since I've changed my diet,
like, I've almost like rolled the clock back 10 years.
I mean, I used to run marathons back to back
and I could do 'em like a week apart or two weeks apart.
And now I'm, like, recovering from ultras,
like, with the same recovery powers.
And, I mean, I just did like a track ultra
ran a couple weeks ago and then came back
and did a 40 miler and broke the course records there.
But, yeah, I mean, whatever I'm doing,
I really think like just the recovery,
the sleep aspect has made a huge difference.
Oh, I forgot to mention.
I'm also taking Epsom salt baths.
And so, that was something that I've just been doing
the past couple weeks that my dietician recommended.
And I did that after my past two races
and it's, like, super charging me.
Right, so that's like mineral absorption
through the skin, basically.
Yeah, yeah.
And do you do, like, the boots,
what do they call the Normatec?
What do they called?
Like recovery?
The Normatec boots, yeah.
Do you use those, too?
Yeah, I do.
Yeah, I have the rapid reboot recovery boots
and I've had those for over five years.
And the first time I knew that they made a difference
was we had traveled to New Zealand with them
to go run the Tarawera Ultramarathon,
and it was the first time after a race
I did not have ankle swelling after the race.
And so, I was kind of like hooked
on the recovery boots after that.
Right, right.
How does it work being married to your coach?
(both laughing)
I think it's okay.
I think it's okay, I mean.
Conor's giving the thumbs up.
He's thumbs down now.
Yeah.
(Camille laughing)
I mean, it has to be, like,
it has to be challenging at times, right?
Yeah.
Like, there's no separation between work and home.
I mean, running is your life for both of you guys.
Obviously, you're both very invested
in each other's success and happiness,
but, you know, it's gotta be challenging
also to not have, like, somebody outside of the home
where you keep it a little bit separate.
But, I don't know, maybe you've never,
you've never really known anything different, right?
Yeah.
You guys have been together for a really long time.
Yeah, yeah, I mean, I'm a different bird.
I'm somebody that'll go run 20 miles at midnight.
And if I had another coach, they wouldn't understand me.
Like, they wouldn't understand my psyche.
I mean, I'm a different bird.
I like to run late at night.
I really don't set any limits on the day and when I run.
And, I mean, if I could, I would run all day.
I would run all day, I'd run twice a day.
So, Conor kind of understands my psyche
and he's with me every day.
He knows what my energy, my mood is like.
You know, I think about, like, 10 years ago,
when I was getting ready to go run a marathon up in Canada
and I was crawling to the bathroom, like, on the floor.
And I had torn my plantar fascia.
And, like, in my mind, it wasn't that bad.
And here I am crawling on the floor and Conor's like,
do you think you should go run a marathon?
(both laughing)
And, yeah, I mean, like, he's the only one
that really understands my psyche and he knows to,
like, pull back the reins on me, like when
I'm obviously exhausted or injured or complaining.
I'm somebody that doesn't really complain about body issues.
And so, if I do complain about something,
that's like a red flag for him.
He knows it's bad, yeah.
Yeah.
And how much of it is your intuition
versus a prescription?
Like, okay, this week, these are the workouts
we're doing or today we're doing this.
And you're like, yeah, but I just want to go run
a marathon at midnight or whatever it is.
(Camille laughing)
Like, what is the push pull?
Like, how locked in is it, or does it just change
and it it's very much, like, day to day?
Like, okay, here's what I think you should do today.
Or you look a little tired today, maybe let's back off.
And when Conor says, this is what you need to do,
is that what you end up doing, or do you,
like, say, yeah, but I feel like doing this.
Like, what does that tension
or relationship or communication look like?
Yeah, so, when he first started coaching me,
like 15, was it 2004, 18 years ago or so,
he used to just tell me what to do and I just did it
without even thinking about what I was doing.
And so, about 2009, he started, like, kind of letting
me have feedback on what I felt like doing.
And so, that was when the magic started to come out.
I felt like when I started to tune in with,
like, what do I feel like doing,
what does my body and my mind feel like doing,
like, that was, like, what elevated me to whole other level.
And so, I think we kind of have that day to day dynamic
that we kind of assess like how I'm feeling,
what the weather's like and, you know,
sometimes I have, like, other commitments for the day
and, like, maybe I had a workout planned
and, you know, just based on, like,
kind of all those factors, you know,
I might move a workout to a different day
or, like, alter the workout.
So, I feel like the only thing that's really changed,
maybe, as I've gotten older is I'm kind of more
in tune with, sometimes I don't do a hard workout.
Like, maybe I'll only do one hard workout a week.
Like, I'm kind of working more with my body.
And rather than being strict,
I'm like having two hard workouts a week,
sometimes I only do one workout
a week if I'm feeling more tired.
So, I feel like I'm kind of more in tune with my body
and not feeling like I have to push it all the time.
That I just really wanna feel good, I wanna be healthy.
I wanna, you know, toe the line for race,
like feeling like really energized and really good.
And you mentioned spreadsheets,
so are you still keeping spreadsheets
and what can be found on those spreadsheets?
Like, what are you tracking specifically
that you're interested in watching?
Yeah, well, I keep Strava, so most of my training
is, like, kept on Strava, but for the spreadsheets,
I just keep track of my mileage and any sort of injuries
or problems I've had through the year.
So, it's not too much detail on the spreadsheets.
I keep it pretty minimal.
But it's incredible to look at because, I mean,
I'm going back, you know, to the seventh grade
and I've kept all these, like, details
of, like, body issues and changes, you know,
going from school to work.
And, yeah, I mean, just it's this
whole evolution of my running career.
But, yeah, I mean, thank goodness for Strava.
(Camille laughing)
Do you use training peaks or any other kind of database
management or you just use Strava?
Yeah, I mean, I've got my COROS watch
which keeps a lot of stats and, you know,
sleep and those sort of things as well.
So, I kind of look at what COROS
is tracking along with Strava.
But, yeah, I mean, it's pretty incredible.
Like, there's so much data that, you know, is out there now,
and I don't even know how to digest all of it.
But, at the same time, I am a bit of a data geek.
Yeah, you're the math person.
Yeah.
(Camille laughing)
Let's talk about the mindset side of things.
Obviously, when you're going a hundred miles or 24 hours,
everybody wants to know, you know,
what are you thinking the whole time,
or when you feel like quitting, what do you tell yourself?
Like, how does all of that work for you?
Yeah, gosh, I mean, there's a lot
of time to think when you're out there.
I'm somebody that, like I said, I train, you know,
for 75% of effort for a hundred miles.
For 24 hours, I'm training for 65 to 70% effort,
which is like an easy run pace.
So, I'm really just channeling my training
and, like, how I felt in my training running at 75%,
running at 65%, and I really just focus on that
and that feeling and that effort.
And, obviously, I'm somebody that,
like, is able to tune out pain
and to tune out the fatigue that I'm feeling.
But I'm also able to tune in to the things
when I need to tune in, you know,
keeping track of, like, how did my feet feel?
And, you know, how's my gut feel.
Like, do I need to change anything with my energy?
So, I'm somebody that kind of like,
I feel like I'm out there just kind of like
meditating a bit, but I'm able
to tune in when I need to tune in
and, you know, make changes when I need to make changes.
Are there any mantras or things that
you tell yourself when it is getting really painful
and you're in that pain cave dark place?
Yeah, oh definitely.
I mean, one of the funny things when I was running
my a hundred mile world record and,
I mean, the sun is like baking on us.
I felt like it was like being like ant
with a magnify glass on us and sitting in this bowl.
And probably just after 50 miles,
I was telling myself to suck it up, Buttercup.
(Camille laughing)
Pretty straightforward, right?
Yeah, suck it up, buttercup.
I mean, that's one of my favorite.
I'm kind of somebody that's like
a tough love type of person.
And, yeah, I mean, I'm out there
and there's certain things like,
I have this mentality that I'm an animal out there
and I'm chasing prey or I'm being chased by an animal.
Which animal are you?
Which animal?
The honey badger, like what is it,
what specific animal are you?
I saw, yeah, I saw your interview with Harvey.
I think he said he was channeling the honey badger.
And, I mean, I think I'm a lion.
I think I'm a lion, especially with my hair.
And you always wear your hair down, don't you?
Yeah, I do, I do.
And I feel like I literally feel
like I have a cape on my head when I run.
Like, it feels like I'm flying out there
and like, my hair just, like, kind of stimulates me
in such a way that I feel, like, free and liberated.
But I feel like I'm an animal out there,
like chasing prey and, I mean, that's like
the mindset that I have even like
racing Harvey here last weekend.
I felt like I was being chased by an animal
and I better, like, I better survive, like, yeah.
Well, I have this theory, I mean, when I look
at you and I'm experiencing you, you're clearly
a very happy person, a very joyful person.
And, again, it's impossible to not compare you
to Courtney's disposition, also a very happy joyful person.
And even like Harvey, Harvey's like a, you know,
he's like overflowing with like gratitude.
And I think it's curious that some of the most successful
ultra runners in the world have this disposition.
And I have to think that there's something to that.
Like, what is the relationship?
Like, if you're a really happy joyful person,
on some level what you're doing
is in pursuit of that joy, right?
So when it gets really hard, like, you have that, right?
And that is in contrast to this idea that
I think is out there that ultra running is hard
and you gotta be tough and it's sort of this
alpha Navy Seal attitude of like tackling obstacles
and all of that, because it's like
you're holding it a little bit lighter, right?
Like, oh, this is fun.
And like, let's remember that this is fun,
you know, when it's really dark.
And I think there's a real strength there.
It would be interesting to, like, study all the elite
ultra runners from that perspective of joy, happiness,
gratitude, because I see it everywhere I look.
Yeah, I think I got it from my parents.
I've seen my parents have their own health issues
and struggles that they go through.
I think about my mom, she had like shoulder surgery
and she had to go through PT for many months
and I've never seen my mom, like, I mean,
my mom is like this, you know, Betty Crocker type that,
you know, like cooks and, you know, she's at home
and she's like, you know, she goes hardcore.
She goes hardcore with her PT and she's so positive.
And she, you know, she was motivated, she's positive.
And I think I got that from my parents.
I mean, growing up, playing sports
and my parents were just such positive people,
like just super motivating and, like, believed in me.
And I think, like, I got it from my parents, yeah.
And you guys lost your home, right, growing up?
Yeah.
To a tornado?
We did, we did.
Yeah, that happened my junior year of high school.
And it actually happened a couple days after prom.
And so, I'd had my prom dress hanging on my bathroom door
and then the tornado happened on a Monday.
And I remember I'd gone to lunch with my friends
that day and it was this perfect sunny day.
And then, yeah, the tornado came and my dad,
so my mom was down in Norman taking
care of my grandpa at the time.
And so, my dad I'd like gotten outta the shower
and my dad was like, hey, there's your tornado coming.
And, you know, we get tornadoes all the time
in Oklahoma, you don't think really anything of it.
You're just like, okay, you know,
I gotta go take shelter, there's a tornado coming.
So, I just grabbed my book bag and went with my dad
and we drove down to Norman
to be with my mom and my grandpa.
And I'm watching the TV and, like,
here's this tornado coming through Oklahoma City
and, you know, telling us the streets
that it's going through and, I mean,
we're like, oh my gosh, that's where we live.
And so, yeah, it just ripped, like,
right through where my high school was,
the neighborhood to the south.
It ripped, like, right where we lived,
which is right across the street from the high school.
But, yeah, it was pretty traumatizing at the time.
So, your whole house was gone.
Yeah, so we actually, so what had happened
was we lived down in Duncan, Oklahoma,
and we had just moved up to the city,
like, a couple months before 'cause my dad
had retired and we were trying to decide,
like, where to live in south Oklahoma City.
And so, we were either gonna live, like,
across the street from the high school
or we were gonna live in another neighborhood.
Both places got hit by the tornado.
And so, we ended up, we had an apartment at the time
'cause my parents were trying to sell their house.
And so, the tornado hit the apartment
where we were staying at.
And so, I mean, it just, there were like four people
where we lived in that vicinity that died.
And so, I mean, I feel so blessed that my dad
had loaded me up in the car to go down to Norman.
And, you know, when we were able to get back up there
and, you know, I mean, it's just concrete slabs up there.
And so, it was really shocking.
I mean, at the time you're thinking, oh my gosh,
like, you know, I can't believe this happened.
But, at the same time, like I felt so grateful for my life
and you know, what my dad had done, you know, to load us up.
And, yeah, I mean, I just felt like this
appreciation for, like, I'm alive.
Like, I can still run, I still have my running talent.
And it kind of, like, made me like become
more spiritual with myself and I felt like,
like I started running long on Sunday as a way
to, like, celebrate my life and, like, my running talent.
And, yeah, and that really like kind of put me back in touch
with myself and, like, being appreciative of my life.
That gratitude thing, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And now you're back there.
Yeah.
Like, you've kind of been nomadic, right?
You were in Colorado, you were in Tucson,
now you're back in Oklahoma City.
Back to Oklahoma, love it.
On the tornado watch.
Yes.
Has there been any since you've been back?
It's pretty recent, right?
Yeah.
You moved back there pretty recently.
Yeah, so we just moved back here a couple months ago
and we have a storm shelter in our house.
(both laughing)
In fact, I've joked I've thought about like...
This is new for Conor, right?
Like, not used to like tornadoes, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, yeah, I haven't even gotten
down in there yet to see what the storm shelter's
like, but we have one in our garage.
So, yeah, you gotta get underground
if a tornado is coming 'cause it's,
yeah, just completely flattens your house.
But, yeah, I mean, I'm from Oklahoma,
I'm a native Oklahoman and my parents live there.
My two sisters live there and I just,
I feel like I'm reconnecting like with my roots
as a runner and, you know, where I'm from.
Yeah, yeah.
So, but it's pretty flat there, right?
Like, you're not getting a lot
of hill work for Western States.
Yeah, so the way that I was able to train and to win
the Comrades marathon was I went down to Mount Scott,
which is like our only, like, mountain in Oklahoma.
(Camille laughing)
Like 1,500 feet high or something.
Yeah, I think it goes up to like
2,000 feet or something like that.
It's like just under three miles
to go up to about 2,000 feet.
It's a pretty steep grade.
Like, I think it goes maybe from, like, 8% up to 20% or so.
But, yeah, that's basically how I trained to win
the Comrades uphill course was driving down to Mount Scott
and doing repeats up and down the mountain.
And then I would do short repeats at the bottom as well.
And so, that was how I trained,
that was how I hill trained for Comrades.
And there's also trails down there to get on.
I really like the trails.
And now is that what you're doing
for Western States or what's the prep like?
Like, this is the big goal.
Yeah.
It's coming up, when is it, in July?
Yeah, the end of June.
End of June, okay.
Yeah.
So, where are we at and what are you focused on?
Like, this is the thing, right?
Yeah.
Like, you've got all these world records,
but, like, it's all about Western States.
Yeah, now I'm trying to bring it to the trail.
So, super fun.
I mean, I'm gonna do the Western States
training camp coming up here in a couple weeks,
which is something I haven't done before.
And, I mean, I ran Western States last year.
And so, I've kind of got like the mental picture
of what it's like and, you know, the different,
you know, you kind of have to think of it in segments
'cause there's so many different parts
and kind of how you break it down.
And I feel like since I've run the whole course,
I can, like, mentally process that better
and how to prepare for it.
But, yeah, I'm planning to go out to the training camp
and get on the course more and just
kind of get dialed in with that flow
and that connection of my body with the course.
But, yeah, I mean, you know, you kind of just try
and put it all together on race day
and you know, hope that you've like, you know,
dialed in all the different components.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You seem really clear on your strengths.
What do you think are your weaknesses
or the areas that really need a little bit more focus?
Yeah, well, definitely one of the things
was my body breaking down and, like,
I've had to drop from races because I had
hamstring issues or just my body breaking down.
And so, I've spent, you know, the past year
really, like, getting in the gym and really
working on my full body strength
so that I'm not breaking down.
And I felt like, even last year, when I ran Western States,
even though I had this iron issue,
my body wasn't breaking down.
Like, I was physically strong
because I'd been working more in the gym.
And so, I felt like that was the first piece of the puzzle
was to get my body physically stronger
so I'm not breaking down in the race.
And then, the whole iron issue was the other
thing that I needed to work on.
I'm somebody that has the opposite problem of most people.
Like, you know, I'm having to give my blood away
rather than, you know, trying to build it up.
So, yeah, I mean, I've really worked on that.
Just trying to get my biomarkers more balanced again.
Yeah, but I feel like you're on top of that, right?
Yeah.
It's like, okay, that was a weakness, I've dealt
with that, what's the next weakness that I need to look at.
Yeah, yeah.
You're like, I'm good, I'm strong, I'm, like, ready to go.
I'm feeling pretty good, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, right now, like,
'cause I've been so focused on road stuff and track running,
like, I'm trying to translate it to the trails right now
and kind of get my flow dialed in to be on trails.
And, I mean, I feel great.
The past couple of weeks that I've gotten
on trails I'm like, man, I feel great.
Like, I feel like, damn, I'm like
flying like uphill and downhill.
And I feel like so much more comfortable
with my technical skills than I did, you know,
a year, a couple years ago.
And, yeah, obviously like, you know,
for me to take on like a course like UTMB
is gonna be like, you know, whole other element.
Right.
But I feel like I'm somebody that can adapt,
you know, I can get stronger, I can, you know, improve.
And, I mean, it's kind of like learning how to ride a bike.
You know, any athlete, you know,
that's trying to learn how to do something new,
like, if you do it, you know, over and over and over again,
eventually you're gonna get it right.
I'm optimistic.
You know, I'm optimistic that if I keep
practicing and I keep working at it,
like, I'm finally gonna get things right.
And how do you like to work with pacers?
Do you want somebody with you as much as possible or you
want a bump and run, just gimme the nutrition and I'm fine.
Or, like, how do you think about that piece?
Yeah, I'm not really, I don't think I want a pacer.
I actually, like a year and a half ago, it was interesting,
I ended up running a road 100K and had a pacer
and that was kind of my first time to have a pacer.
And I feel like I'm somebody that likes to get
into my own head that I don't like to be distracted.
I don't like to have a whole lot of people or,
like, outside, like, influence.
I really need to be in my own head space when I race.
And, I mean, that's kind of what I'm good at.
Like, getting in my own head when I race
and really, like, elevating myself.
And so, I'm actually not gonna have pacers.
Like, I feel pretty confident enough in my own self
that I can get in my own head space and like,
you know, to elevate myself like later in the race.
Yeah, yeah.
Talk a little bit about the longer term goals.
I mean, Western States is a short term goal.
Like, what's further down the horizon in terms
of things that you'd like to be able to accomplish?
Yeah, so, obviously, I wanna become more
of a trail runner and I'm really motivated.
I've been studying world records for many years now.
And, I mean, there's still some more world records
like in the multi-day stuff that I wanna get,
but I see myself evolving more into trail running
and mountain running and I wanna become
the first athlete to win Comrades, Western States,
UTMB because that's the triple crown of ultra running.
And so, winning Comrades is obviously the hardest one
because it's the most competitive race to win
and there's only been three Americans that have done it.
So, I feel like, you know, I won like the pinnacle,
you know, as far as Comrades.
But, yeah, now I've gotta bring it to Western States
and UTMB and yeah, it's gonna be a lot of fun
trying to, you know, achieve that.
But, yeah, I mean, I feel like
there's no limits on what I can do.
Right.
Like, if I set a goal for something,
like I'm somebody that doesn't really
limit myself on, like, I just go after it,
I just, you know, bite down and go after that goal.
I feel like you would really excel at Badwater.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, definitely.
I was actually signed up to do Badwater
two years ago and it got canceled.
Right.
And so, yeah, I've been staying with my friend Shannon,
who's done it like eight times and I mean,
she's all raving to me about it.
And, in fact, she actually did the double Badwater.
She ran Badwater and then turned
around and ran back to the start.
So I don't know.
Shannon, so we should just shout her out.
Like, Shannon Farar-Griefer she's a legend.
She lives in the area.
If you run trails around here,
you're inevitably gonna bump into her.
She's amazing.
Yeah.
And, yeah, was she the first to do the double
or, I can't remember, it was a while ago when she did it.
Yeah.
But it's, like, unbelievable.
Yeah, I mean, she was talking about how tired
she was when she finished and she turned
around and ran it all the way back.
I know.
I mean, that's so mental, like, it's incredible, yeah.
What about a transcontinental run?
Oh, absolutely, yeah.
I mean, I've got a long list of things I wanna do.
I mean, we're watching Michael Wardian
right now do transcon.
I mean, that stuff just totally blows my mind.
Like, I feel like I'm somebody that, I mean,
I find joy in running period, and to run across America,
I would just absolutely love it.
I mean, it would be something completely new
because you would see the entire country by foot.
And I think I would just love that.
I think I would just, like, be taking it in every day,
like, being in a new place and knowing,
you know, where my legs are taking me.
What's the women's record for that.
Do you know?
Yeah, I don't really know what that is.
I think Pete Kostelnick holds the men's record
and I've run a little bit further than him for 24 hours
so I think I would be trying to go for his record.
That would be unbelievable.
Yeah.
If you broke the world record
for men and women doing that.
Yeah, yeah, oh, totally.
Yeah.
And then there's all these FKT's, right?
Like, you could, I mean, there's no limit.
Yeah.
It's just a question of, like,
where you wanna place your attention.
And I think you've even mentioned the 3,100.
Yeah.
In Queens.
Yes.
Which is a wild one.
That, I mean, that is just so, that blows my mind.
(Camille laughing)
I mean, 3,100 miles, like around, like,
I think it's like a half mile block.
I mean, how do you stay motivated?
How do you find joy, you know, when it's boring?
And I think I'm somebody that like, I mean,
I like to use the energy around me when I'm in races
and you kind of have to break it down.
Like, how do you eat an elephant?
You eat an elephant one bite at a time.
And so, I've learned like when I run races,
like I need to, you know, track the mileage
and I need to break down the how
am I going to eat the elephant?
Yeah.
And so, I mean, that's something I think about in races.
Like, you know, whether I'm going 100 miles, 24 hours,
3,100 miles, like how do you break down eating the elephant?
Well, you're no stranger to running around in circles.
(Camille laughing)
So, you're running around in a circle.
The interesting thing with that
one is the course closes at night.
So, you go to bed and it becomes like a job for the summer.
You just wake up and between eight and five or whatever,
eight and eight or whatever the hours are,
you just go around that loop
and try to get as many miles as you can.
There's a documentary about it that my friend,
Sanjay Rawal, made, I don't know if you've seen it.
Yeah.
And it's so interesting.
The people that excel in that race are not the people,
like, they don't look like runners,
they're, like, average people with,
you know, all different kinds of jobs
and it really shows you like, oh,
this is about mental fortitude.
Yeah.
This is about like something more than athletic capacity.
This is about like...
Spiritual.
A connection to something beyond.
Like, those are the people that seem to, you know, excel.
Yeah. Yeah and I feel that.
I feel a spiritual connection.
When I go for world records, I feel like
I'm tapping into something really special inside of me.
And I reach a point where I, like, transcend.
And, like, it's almost like my head
starts to float off of my body.
And I think when you do something like that,
you really have to tap into that spiritual energy
inside of you to keep going and to complete it.
'Cause it's just something that just, like, you know,
it's just like beyond, like, what you think is possible.
Tell me more about that.
(Camille laughing)
Yeah, I feel like I've always had this ability
to tap into this extra energy inside of me.
And I, like, I remember when I set my 50 mile
world best back in 2015, I think I had,
like, maybe it's like 12 miles to go,
and I joked that it was like that
the hand of God came over me.
And I literally felt like my head
started to float on my body
and I'm just like a machine those last 12 miles.
And it was kind of one of those points where I was
either gonna get the record or not get the record.
And I felt like I just found some sort of,
like, spiritual connection where my body just became
a machine and it was kind of like my head was floating.
And I felt that like many more times
when I've gone for world records.
I feel like, even I think about when I did
my 12 hour world record, I started to feel that.
I feel like I kind of just went
into this, like, machine mode.
And, yeah, I mean, it was like, it's incredible.
I just feel it, I feel this energy that I can
tap into when I go for these amazing things.
Like this advanced flow state where
you become this channel for something else.
Yeah, yeah.
I feel it, like, it's incredible.
Like, even racing Harvey, I mean, it was like,
I just transcended like this last couple miles
and I don't know how to describe it.
Like, I just, it's like I almost like detach a bit
from my body and from the pain I'm feeling
and I just become this machine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's wild.
Well, that's why you have to do the 3,100.
It is this self transcendent run.
Yes.
That's what it's called, right?
Yeah, absolutely.
I feel like that's gonna be like my finale as a runner.
How do you think about yourself as a role model?
Obviously, you're inspiring to everybody,
but particularly to women, women athletes, young girls.
I'm sure you have opportunities
to speak with younger people.
Like, how do you think about how you carry yourself
and what that means for the next
generation of young athletes?
Yeah, well, when I'm out there and I'm going,
I'm about to do something, I mean,
I think about that not only the people that inspire me
to do a race, I feel like every race that I do,
I have somebody that is inspiring me and that I think about.
Like, especially later in the race.
But I also know that people are watching me
and that I'm bringing an inspiration to other people.
And I feel that, I feel that during the race.
I feel like, you know, I'm doing this for the world.
I'm doing this to, you know, elevate the sport.
To raise the bar in what women think is possible.
And, like, it's such a powerful thing when you're out there.
I feel like it's not just me
trying to reach a personal goal.
I'm doing this for the sport.
I'm creating history.
And it just like, totally like elevates me,
like, later in the race, just thinking about that.
And now being 40, you're not just breaking barriers
in distance and time, you're breaking barriers in age.
Like, you haven't even begun to, you know,
tap into what you're capable of.
I'm sure you've got a whole slew of world records,
you know, coming, but it's really cool
because it creates this conversation around what
we're capable of and what our limits are as we age.
And, as you redefine it, you're in equal parts,
inspiring young people, as you are to,
like, the older people who are trying to, you know,
rethink what they're capable of as we get older.
Yeah, absolutely.
That's awesome.
I mean, I think about when I reached my mid thirties,
I thought it was on some sort of like
downhill slope or something.
And, I mean, probably a lot of like marathoners
and, you know, ultra athletes think that.
They think that, oh, you know, it's all downhill from here.
But I feel like I'm reaching my prime right now.
And, I mean, it's incredible because here
I've been a runner for 27 years
and I'm still getting better, you know, at age 40.
And, you know, I feel like I'm kind of dialing in more,
like I talked about my diet and my recovery.
I'm kind of dialing in more on those factors that,
you know, maybe I just kind of let them slide in the past.
Sure.
And wasn't really as dialed in on them.
So I'm kind of showing like, you know,
if I'm using like more of my brain and having more wisdom
with my training, my recovery, my diet,
all these things and it's, like, working.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it's also cool that we're in a time where,
you know, somebody who is of your age
can live as a professional athlete.
Like, you have sponsors and you can make a living
and, you know, do your thing and I think that's amazing.
Like, that wouldn't have been possible,
you know, maybe even like 10 years ago, you know?
Oh yeah.
Yeah, oh definitely.
I mean, I like, I mean, I've been this sport for seven years
and I've seen this whole evolution with sponsorships.
Even when I first got into the sport, it was actually
hard to get sponsorships, even being a woman.
I felt like I saw, like, more younger men
getting sponsorship opportunities.
And I, like, here I was, I had done a lot
in, like, just my first year as an ultra runner
and I felt like that there was
kind of more this focus on men.
And it's kind of shifted now that
there's so many amazing women doing things
and sponsors have realized like, oh,
you know, like, we've got these amazing women
that, you know, we can back.
And I feel like there's kind of been
this shift of supporting more women.
And more women, more athletes of,
you know, all different ages as well.
I mean, I'm, you know, just turned 40
and I'm professional athlete.
And, I mean, I had a profession
before I was a professional athlete.
Right.
That, you know, I thought I would
be working in research for the rest of my life.
I couldn't have imagined that
I'm a professional athlete at age 40.
Like, this is just wild.
Right, like, were you working in a lab in like Ann Arbor,
like studying bone density or something?
Yeah.
Yeah, I worked at the University of Oklahoma
Health Science Center, but I also worked
at Michigan for a period back in 2016.
And so, I mean, I had a dedicated career,
like, I was not expecting to become this ultra runner,
this professional athlete, you know, at this age.
And I had to go through a transition
trying to transition from my profession,
my day job, to become a professional athlete.
I mean, it was like, oh my gosh, what do I do with this?
Right.
But, yeah, once I had my car accident back in 2019
and, I mean, I was driving to work that day
and I felt like it was almost like this sign from above
telling me, you know, this is where it stops.
Like, you know, go full time with your running.
And I mean, I'm grateful.
I feel like I'm doing what I'm born to do as a runner.
And it's empowering, like, you know, to be doing this.
And I'm grateful for that.
I wanna be the best that I can be
and to do everything right.
Yeah, and on a practical level,
so you have your sponsors and then,
do you guys also coach other people
or like, how does it work so that
all the bills get paid and you can travel?
'Cause it's expensive to travel around and go
to all these races and do all that kind of stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, fortunately, I've got a lot of support from Hoka.
So, Hoka is my main sponsor and, you know,
I've got a travel budget with them.
But, yeah, we also coach on the side,
you know, which keeps my husband busy.
Yeah.
But, yeah, I mean, we coach together and, you know,
that's what I'm doing a lot in my free time, you know,
we're trying to work with our athletes.
And, yeah, just communication with athletes
and that sort of thing.
So, yeah, we started our coaching business, you know,
back when I was still working full time in research.
And, I mean, that was really helpful, you know,
trying to transition into becoming
a full-time athlete along with, you know,
having our own business was really beneficial.
But I feel it's so cool for me to be able
to give back my knowledge and my wisdom
to the running community and to see
other athletes, like, succeed.
We just coached the guy that, and Joe McConaughy
that just won the Cocodona 250.
I mean, he just crushed it here last week.
And, I mean, it's really cool to be able to use,
you know, my experience and my wisdom
to give back to other athletes and see
somebody like him, you know, just crush it.
Right, right, right.
On that note, what do you see, like,
a lot of people doing wrong or what are common mistakes
that the amateur athlete makes when
they're participating in these longer races?
Yeah, I mean, I would say as far as mistakes
that athletes make, I would say too many
athletes run their easy days too fast.
And so, we really have to pull back the reins
on the athletes that we coach
that people don't know how to run easy.
They don't know how to run relaxed.
Well, Strava doesn't help with that.
(Camille laughing)
That's true.
You know, 'cause every time you're out there,
you're like, what's this gonna look like on Strava?
I don't want to be judged for running slow.
Like, I don't think it's good for that, you know?
Yeah, I think it turns people into workout champs.
I mean, I look at Strava sometimes
and I'm like, oh my gosh, like it's mind boggling
some of the workouts that people are doing
and their easy days are hard.
Like, every day is, like, hard.
They don't have any concept of pulling
back the reins and running easy
on their easy days, hard on their hard days.
It seems like every day is hard.
So, yeah, I mean, with the athletes that we coach,
you know, we're really trying to get them
to pull back their pace on the easy runs.
But then, the other thing is
we don't do back to back long runs.
We don't believe in, we think it's too much stress.
And so, when we start coaching athletes and they're like,
you know, where's our 40 mile training run.
Right, that's a standard thing in ultra prep.
Yeah.
Like, doing a long run on tired legs.
So the back to back is a big part of that.
Yeah, so even coaching Joe for Cocodona, you know,
he thought he needed be to be doing a lot of burn,
he needed be doing a lot of long runs,
and we just really pulled back the reins with his training.
He's the type of guy that, he ran in college
so he has a lot of like natural leg speed.
And so, we worked more with his natural physiology
and he thrived on that, like, and he went into Cocodona
and he felt like he was pretty strong,
like, most of the race and I think a lot of it
is just that he's not over trained.
He went into the race, like, pretty fresh.
He had done a 100K, like, a couple weeks
before as a race as, like, his last, like, long run.
But then, you know, we had him
come back and do a speed session
a couple days after that and he just crushed it.
So, we kind of worked more with his natural physiology
rather than, you know, doing all these,
like, back to back long runs and extreme amounts of burn.
Right, but I also find myself thinking,
as somebody who doesn't have a background in running,
I have a background in swimming and other things,
but you having this, you know,
elite background and Joe is his name?
Yeah, Joe.
Having a background as a really good runner
makes it make more sense, like, okay,
you don't need to do your long runs longer than 22.
Like, 'cause you're tapping into, you know,
two decades or a decade plus of that type of background.
But if you're an amateur runner who's kind of new
to all of this and doesn't have that.
Yeah.
I think on a confidence level, they need to do a longer
run just to convince themselves, like, it's possible.
But maybe there's something, too, like those
back to back long hard runs that, you know,
that fills the gap because they didn't have that,
you know, experience as a younger person.
Yeah, I kind of feel like doing races, you know,
gives people the confidence and the way to prepare
for whatever sort of like A goal race.
Even I do that.
I mean, I like to, when I'm going for, you know,
training for a big race, like a world championship,
I like to do, like, a marathon or a 50K
a couple weeks out, you know, it's like my last,
like, long run, you know, for that big race.
And I mean, that's kind of the mindset
that we have coaching the athletes.
That we, you know, try to do, like, you know,
something big like a couple weeks
before their, like, A race and you know,
that kind of like helps them to practice,
you know, their nutrition and spending,
you know, more time on their feet.
But, yeah, I feel like doing all these,
like, back to back long runs,
I feel like it's too much stress.
And, I mean, I have a master's degree
in exercise and sports science and, I mean,
I just can't really justify from a science standpoint,
like, there's just too much stress,
like, from doing so many long runs.
I feel like it beats you down.
And when I've tried that, when I've tried
to do, like, 30 mile plus training runs,
I mean, I feel like I get tired.
I'm like, I don't feel like this is necessary.
And so, yeah, when I like pulled back the reins,
like, I feel like, you know,
if you pull back the reins and you know,
you're finding that perfect formula to have, like,
a race, like, a couple weeks out,
that that kind of gets you dialed in.
And then just, you know, taper and recover
for the race, the big race.
Yeah, yeah, that's really interesting.
The final thing I wanted to ask you about has
to do with diversity in ultra running.
I mean, obviously, it's a very kind
of, like, white sport, you know.
I think it is really cool that there's so much enthusiasm
and excitement around women in ultra running.
And that's where it's most exciting, I think,
because of people like you who are
really pushing boundaries and advancing
the conversation of what's possible.
But how can we make it a little bit more inclusive?
I know this is something that you care about,
you know, so elaborate on that a little bit.
Yeah, well, it's really interesting
when I go to Comrades and that Comrades
is probably the most diverse race in the world
as far as ultra running and yeah, and then
you look at trail running and things
and, you know, tend to be a little less diverse.
And I think one thing that Comrades has going
for it is they have a very small entry fee.
I don't know what the conversion is
for their amount to enter the race,
but they have a different entry fee
for international versus within South Africa.
And so, I think of, you know, money,
the cost of getting into a race.
Like, that's one barrier, for sure.
And I feel like, you know, maybe trial running
needs to have some sort of subsidized,
like, entry fees or something to, you know,
to allow like more people to afford it.
But, yeah, I think that, yeah, and I mean,
Comrades is kind of like brings in like a global, like,
I don't know, it just seems like they have like this, like,
like it's kind of like the world
coming together type of thing.
Yeah.
But, also, there's such a steep tradition.
There around it.
Like, everybody there knows about it and everybody,
like, it was the whole community just kind of does it
whether they're trained to do it or not.
Yeah, yeah, and I feel like, I don't know,
maybe, you know, there needs to be more collaboration
between like what Comrades is doing right
and trying to bring that more to trail running.
But, yeah, just try to, you know,
think about what are the barriers to allowing,
you know, more diverse, you know, community.
You know, I follow, like, the Black Trail Runners,
I think they're based in the UK and, you know,
just trying to create a community
to get more diversity into the sport.
There's also like the Native American Trail Runners.
I think I actually donated towards their cause.
You donated your prize money towards that, right?
Yeah, yeah, and I feel like this,
like I need to give back more.
Like, I feel like, you know,
even if I'm getting prize money or, you know,
what are the ways that I can give back to the sport?
You know, do I donate part of my prize money?
Like, you know, get more active with, you know,
trying to promote these causes and, you know,
Black Trail Runners and Native American Trail Runners.
Yeah, I mean, I feel like that there's ways that,
you know, we need to acknowledge, you know,
that, hey, you know, we're a pretty welcoming community
and, you know, anybody can do our sport.
But, yeah, I think it's pretty cool, you know,
that there's a greater awareness of that too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, well, before I let you go,
I think it would be good to kind of round
this out with just some parting words
for somebody who's been listening to this
or watching it and is feeling inspired
and thinking, maybe I can do one of those.
Like, that's cool.
Like, how does somebody begin this process
of tackling a big challenge?
Or how do you inspire or motivate somebody to get
off the couch and start thinking about raising
their ceiling on what they're capable of?
Yeah, well, I mean, I think back
to when I was a marathoner,
I mean, even when I did the half marathon,
I remember when I did the half marathon
thinking it felt like a marathon.
And it seems like every time I've gone up in distance,
I'm like, you know, I spent many years doing marathons
and then I kind of wondered what's next.
Like, what's next?
What can I do next?
And, yeah, I mean, going into ultra running,
it was kind of like deep diving into,
you know, a whole other sport.
And, you know, fortunately I did it.
Fortunately, I had the courage to do it.
But now, you know, being able to give back to the sport
as a coach, that's what I recommend to athletes.
I mean, I'm willing to help athletes, you know,
to make that deep dive, you know, and help them
have the guidance and the confidence to do it.
But, yeah, I mean, obviously, I feel like
there's kind of this step up and, you know,
sometimes there's even ultra runners
who have stepped down in distance.
I think about like Jim Walmsley stepped
down into the marathon, which is really cool.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, yeah, I mean, I feel like it takes
courage to do that, but obviously, you know,
being a coach, I wanna give back and, you know,
help athletes, you know, to make that jump, you know,
whether to step up or step down in distance.
Well, you're an inspiration and I think
there's gonna be a lot of new fans coming your way.
Thank you.
Everybody's excited to see what you do
at Western States and after that.
So, I appreciate you coming here today and sharing with me.
Well, thank you.
Thank you for the conversation.
Your energy is amazing.
It really is infectious.
Thank you.
And you're a beautiful person, so thank you.
Aw, thank you, appreciate it.
Keep doing your thing.
I just, like, it's so cool.
You're just knocking these things down like bowling pins.
(both laughing)
You know, like, nothing's in your way.
Yeah, it's all in the mind and just determination and joy.
I'm propelled by joy.
The joy thing is big, right?
Yeah, absolutely.
And it doesn't, it's very authentic to you.
It's not like, oh, I'm trying to be joyful
because if I'm joyful, then I'll be a better athlete.
It's not, like, it doesn't work that way, but.
I'm just a happy person.
Yeah.
How do you think you're so happy. (Camille laughing)
Yeah is that what?
Married to an Irishman, yeah.
Well, I was, I mean, I was born on Christmas day
and they said, I came into the world smiling.
There you go.
So, yeah, I came into the world smiling.
And you've just always been this way.
Yeah, my mom said I was just a happy baby
and, yeah, I liked to eat.
(Camille laughing)
Okay.
I like to run, I like to eat, I mean, I just, yeah.
And now you get to do those things.
Yeah.
Professionally.
Yeah, cool. Well, come back and talk to me again
after you break a bunch of more world records.
And we'll get Conor on with you next time together.
And we can, like, get into the spreadsheets.
(Camille laughing)
There you go.
Cool.
If anybody wants to learn more about you,
should they just go to your website,
Camille Herron or you're on all the socials
and all of that, you share tons of stuff.
I love the little video of you face planting on the trail.
(Camille laughing)
That's like pinned on your Twitter.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, that was like, that was a drone.
I had no idea there was a drone that captured me,
like face planting on the trail.
And I got back up and was like bloody
and everything and just kept going to the finish.
Right, so if you wanna see that, go to Camille's Twitter.
Yeah.
And your website and anywhere else?
Yeah, I mean, I'm in Instagram @runcamille
and I mean, I get messages all the time.
I'm pretty interactive on, like,
all the social media platforms.
I really like interacting, commenting,
and you know, I meet people at races.
I meet people at races and they're like, oh yeah,
I follow you and I mean, it's just really cool...
It's cool.
Like, when I meet people in person, I'm like, yeah,
we like, you know, exchange messages and things.
So, shoot her a DM and she might answer you,
you know, and say hi at the next race.
All right, thanks so much, appreciate it.
Yeah, thank you, Rich, cool.
Peace, thanks.
(mellow music)